Mày emy chiến thắng từ tổn mỹ thương, chủ tính nước tổn lâm và đoàn không tác đã đến dân hương,
dân hoa tại cù mộ đại tướng vọng bên giáp tại sạch của trạch.
Và khu dí tích lịch sự cuốc gia đặt biệt biến phà dành của bác dành và nghĩa chăng
lịch sĩ cuốc gia trường sơn, chóng khu khí trang nghiêm, đoàn bây tỏ thành kính,
chiến sâu sắc đại tướng vọng bên giáp, vị tướng viên thoại, tổng tướng tướng
lệnh cun đổi nhân dân Việt Nam, người có nhiều đón có tò lớn cho sự nghiệp cách mạc,
tại biến phà dành, đoàn đá dân hương, tưởng niệm cay hùng lệ sĩ trong khẳng chiến trống Mỹ
nơi đây là điểm dấu thông chiến lược trên tuyến xí viện bác năm,
thứng chiếu hàng nguyên trận đánh phá ác liệt của không quân, hai quân Mỹ,
hàng chăm cán mộ trên sĩ công nhân và lực lượng dân quân, thành nghiên xuống phong đã hì xin để rử vững mặt mẫu dấu thông.
Ngay này, giết tích quốc gia đặt biệt biến phà dành trở thành địa chỉ đó trong giáo dục chuyển thông kết mạc.
Tại đây, tổn bị thư chủ tính nước tổ lâm đã ghi số vàng liệu niệm và giang hương tại tượng đại chiến thắng của hai quân nhân dân Việt Nam.
Gián cùng ngày, tổn bị thư chủ tính nước tổ lâm đã tới dân hương, dân hoa tại nghệ trang lệ sĩ quốc gia chừng sơn,
nơi như ghi có hơn mở in hai chăm đệ sĩ đã hì xin trên tuyến đường mòn hủ chỉ mình, chăm thời kỳ khẳng chiến trống Mỹ kêu nước,
tại các điểm đến dân hương, tổn bị thư chủ tính nước tổ lâm cùng bản không tác,
bây to lòng thành kính và nguyện cùng tòan đàng, bản dân, tòan quân, đòan kết một lòng, ra sự phần đầu,
tiếp tục đi theo con đường cách mạng mà đàng bác ngô và các thế giải cách mạc đi trước đã lửa cho.
Tế tục kiến đệnh chủ nghĩa mắt lên đến từ tượng hủ chim mình,
li tưởng độc lập dân tộc và trung nhạc sáng hội, xây dựng một nước Việt Nam hoa bình, độc lập dân chủ,
giáo mạng, phôn viên, vàng mình, hạnh phúc.